[Music]
good morning John
it's Wednesday May 30th
I was really surprised suddenly to
discover that I needed to do a song
today so I decided yesterday after I
realized that I would say something
extremely random from your video and
make a song about it
I was extremely surprised to find that
you gave me something ridiculously
random to deal with
[Music]
the first history
cuz found where to gather enough power
to put millions in their graves and just
focused on is why
while Hitler's war took 70 million but I
got to wonder those kind words
then Queen
[Music]
one of the first they call my queen of
Madagascar she'll sell you slavery your
boy
she'll dress you up the bloody animal
skins the dogs
a nation died on
laughs that love
was cost it was Queen run either loan
are the first rival on a runnable on a
rebel on the first
Oh
I did it so yesterday's video packing
already moving oh my god leaving New
York that's scary and I'm sorry and I
hope that I don't have to do that
anytime soon oh so much lifting also in
reference to your last video amazing
Yeti I'm undone on a more serious note
I've been a little bit disappointed
lately of the coverage of coal now we
all know that coal is bad but we need it
to power all of our lights and stuff but
the worst thing in the world would be to
find more ways to use coal there are
people trying to figure out how to use
coal to power automobiles I have to
wonder if you know that your favorite
guy mr. Obama is a champion for coal to
liquid technology I mean he's really
photogenic and well-spoken and
everything but this kind of turns me off
I'm also angry that there's been clean
coal out has been popping up all over
the place
I keep it on some environmental blogs
one of the advertisements is a lump of
coal with legs that runs and skips and
jumps and is happy he has thought
bubbles that say happy things I have
cleared out his thought bubble so that
people can have him say whatever they
think that he would actually say I would
like to encourage nerdfighters to do
that the graphics below and you can send
them to sparks fly pudgy millicom or put
them in the comments the best one may
even win a prize Don I will see you
tomorrow